protests are rare here in China's Tibet
region but these migrant workers are
angry they came here to make money and
haven't been able to a coveted lockdown
has stopped this city for the last three
months
lockdowns are being imposed all across
the country in Beijing testing positive
for Coronavirus can lead to Long
quarantine no pay and isolation from
friends and family
yes I'm worried of course I'm worried I
have been affected by it I've been
quarantined twice this year I'm
basically afraid to go out and have
dinner with friends because it may
affect my work China has reported a
thousand new coveted 19 cases for the
third day in a row a small number by
global standards but it sent 28 cities
into lockdown impacting more than 200
million people
we rent and share an apartment in
Beijing and sometimes it's
nerve-wracking once there's a case
somewhere and then you become a close
contact you've got to be in quarantine
it's also quite expensive so that's
difficult too I've been through two
centralized quarantines
proof of negative PCR test is required
to enter most places including public
transport waiting in line for a test can
take several hours and needs to be
repeated every few days but no one will
be waiting in line at Universal resort
in Beijing the theme park is the latest
company to close after contact tracing
showed a spread in cases over the
weekend the strict measures weigh
heavily on those who live under them
I feel my worries have become a form of
numbness now I've come to accept it
worries that won't end until everyone
here tests negative Leah Harding Al
Jazeera